minha preparação física para um
campeonato internacional de boxe hein
então aqueço com esse exercício que
parece de parto humanizado depois cinco
minutos na esteira depois vem 10
segundos de desgraça de escada de
agilidade 10 segundos de descanso depois
eu boto os cavalos Romano Imaginário
para correr dá para ver que eu amo com
essa cara de Kiko aí Bam depois mais
escada meu Deus para que tanto esses
cara fala meu Deus não tem rampa não
cadê a sensibilidade eu já querendo
morrer arrependido só meter em confusão
Então vamos jogar bola no chão Bora
jumento velho depois as pernas já morta
pula pra lá pra casa sozinho pingando em
câmera lenta ali passando na frente do
pics bets Caso vocês querem apostar em
mim aqui eu já arrependi de tudo isso
essa desgraça e vem o rolinho para fazer
o abdômen eu odeio esse homem me matar o
jumento pra correr de novo vai se meter
em confusão depois exercício terra e
repete tudo de novo cada exercício com
10 segundos de descanso tomada tome bola
aqui eu já sabia o exercício que vinha
depois se o diabo amasso o pão é com
esse rola depois pra recuperar os
músculos banheira de gelo os ovos sobe
tanto que quase vira amígdala
chapeuzinho pra não necrosa as orelha e
eu fico 10 minutinhos aí dentro
refletindo que o pics bett é o único
apoiador fora minhas próprias marcas
tamo junto pics Bad
[Música]